>>Steve Chabon: Here at the College
Preparatory School in Oakland,
California, collaborative
learning is one
of the most important ways
our students learn and grow.
>>Harrison: In math we
work in groups every day,
asking each other questions
before we ask the teacher.
>>Maya: In English, we lead
our own round table discussions
to deepen our understanding
of the books we read.
>>David Markus: College Prep is one
of the top private high schools
in the country and a terrific
model for collaborative learning.
The good news, their practices are
both replicable and affordable.
Take a look at what they
do for their students.
It may change what you
decide to do for yours.
>>Monique DeVane: College Prep School
is a fifty-two-year-old school.
It was founded by two women who
had a strong vision of a place
where academics could really thrive.
>>The collaborative
teaching and learning
that we do here is
really distinctive.
Individual work can be a
great way to master content,
but what the group
work empowers and kind of
enables is a student's
cultivation of a certain resilience.
How do you look to your
neighbor as a resource,
how do you test your own theories,
how do you understand if you're
on the right track
or the wrong track?
The sort of habits of mind
that actually are the
underpinnings of deeper scholarship.
>>Betsy Thomas: We have forty-five-
minute classes
and the math classes meet every day.
The kids come in and
they go over the homework
in their groups by comparing answers.
>>Boy: I got the square root
of B squared plus A squared.
>>Betsy: And then if
they're having no resolution,
like a problem was too hard for
everybody, that's the signal that says
that we need to talk about
a problem or two as a class.
>>Aidan: The thing I like most about
the group work is how easy it is
to get help if you're
stuck on a problem.
I mean, you can just ask one
of your group-mates to help you
and everybody's really
ready to lend a hand.
>>Boy: That's these two lines
and then we do the slope
formula from zero to there.
>>Betsy: All right, here
comes classwork, thirty.
The ones I care most
about are one and two.
>>Girl: And then it says, draw
the segment from AB to CD,
so we just connect those points.
>>Betsy: We designed the
classwork problems to be harder
than the homework problems.
The homework problems tend
to be more straightforward
and the classwork problems
are much meatier.
And so in order for them to
actually accomplish them,
they have to talk to each other.
>>Ethan: For harder problems,
usually our group will work together
and we can usually come to
a solution, just by putting
like little pieces of it together.
>>I got negative B
over C for one and two.
>>I don't think it's negative
B over C because it's--
>>Yeah, but there's this--
>>Betsy: The best groups talk
about the problems before
they take pencil to paper.
You really tell, their faces
are directed towards each other.
They are, you know, looking
at each other's papers,
and they're learning so much more.
They're learning how to be
proactive, they're learning how
to depend on their peers.
>>Girl: Today you will work
as a team of surveyors,
putting to use your
knowledge of basic compass
and straight edge constructions.
Your only tools will be a length
of rope and a piece of chalk.
>>Ethan: I feel like when
we work outside together,
it just kind of brings our group
together a little bit more.
>>Aidan: You needed someone
to hold the rope and someone
to move the chalk, and so it
was just like the next step
in collaboration was working
together to make one big end result.
>>Julie Anderson: What I do in my classroom
is I try to make the kids feel
as comfortable and as safe
to be able to take the risks
that will create a good conversation.
On the first day of class
with the ninth grade,
I start by asking the students, "What
are the values implicit in sitting
around this large,
wooden, oval table?"
And they come up with
a list on their own.
First and foremost is
respect, and also listening
to each other, being courteous.
Having the right geography of the
classroom, it's really important.
I always make sure before we start
class, "Can you all see each other?
Can you make eye contact
with your classmates?"
And if you can't, I have them adjust
their chairs so that they can.
I always tell the kids,
"Check your ego at the door.
Be willing to take risks and just
have fun and just throw out idea.
And you throw something else
out and it's not fully formed,
that's great because somebody else
can jump in and build on an idea."
Another sort of easy trick I
have is to start with a kind
of a reflective moment,
a moment of silence
or just a little moment of writing.
>>Remembering you want to have your
feet firmly planted on the floor.
Then the next thing you want
to do is focus on the breath.
Aah. How was that.
>>You know, it only takes a couple
minutes, but just having that moment
to let out the anxiety is great,
because it really can improve
their concentration for the class,
so that they're able to have that
kind of engaged conversation.
>>And if you guys need
a little bit of extra--
>>What's important is to have a
set of guidelines for the students.
>>In this conversation,
we're going to have--
I'm going to have you guys
write down the questions,
and then talk to each other about
the conversation, about the book,
and I'm going to sort of
step back and take notes.
And I'll do a little bit of guiding,
but you guys are going
to talk to each other.
>>And there's three particular
roles that students will fill.
One is the scribe role, where
one student is taking notes
on the conversation, so that all the
other students can be fully engaged
in the conversation that's happening.
Another role is a little map
where one student is
monitoring who's speaking when
and they draw these sort of
diagrams so that there's a visual map
of how the conversation is going.
>>The other thing I just want to
point out since I'm showing these
to you is, would you say
this is a good conversation?
>>Yes.
>>How about that?
>>No.
>>Julie: And then the third
role is the moderator role.
>>Hannah: So I was the moderator
and it was my job to make sure
that we didn't stay on one topic
for too long or move too quickly.
It was also my job to make
sure that everybody talked.
>>Okay, I think we should hear
from someone who hasn't talked yet.
>>Boy: Thea, Caroline, Noah, Max.
>>Boy: Well, Athena's making him
seem godlike, so I think he's just
like taking a gamble
at establishing--
>>Hannah: When we're having a
conversation, you really feel
like you're part of the conversation
and not like, oh, you're sitting
in the back of class and you
can't actually see the person
who's talking.
And also, it's a great way for people
to exchange ideas back and forth
and sort of have everyone contribute.
>>Girl: Who do you think is the
modern equivalent to Odysseus?
>>Boy: Tebow.
>>Julie: In addition to setting
up the conversation
the first time around,
at the end of each
Harkness discussion,
to sort of take a few minutes to
sort of check in with the students
and ask, "Well, how did we do?"
>>How did you do?
How do you think that went?
>>Hannah: I liked that.
>>Girl: I mean, I feel like I learned
a lot more when we discuss things
and we get deeper into it, so.
>>Julie: Great, Eli,
how does it look?
>>And I like to keep those
maps so that we can kind
of chart the progress in
terms of Harkness discussions.
>>And those who talked not so much,
right, maybe step in a little bit,
and if other people can help them,
because it really is
a group effort, right?
Some people just need
a little bit more help
and a little bit of space to do it.
So next time we do it, let's be
mindful of that, but I think overall,
you guys did a really terrific job.
>>Teaching in this discussion-based
way is really the most challenging
but also the most exciting
form of teaching I know.
It never gets old, and honestly,
I feel like I still have
a lot to learn about it.
>>Monique: I think the special
sauce at College Prep is really
about the kind of community values
that kids find when they come here.
They think they're coming for a
first rate academic preparation,
and that certainly is the
centerpiece of what we're doing,
but what I think makes us special
and distinct is actually this culture
of respecting the individual, of
celebrating the small victories,
of kind of enthusiastically embracing
all parts of the learning experience.